so last year I finished 9th grade in 5
months we're homeschooled through an
online program and with that program you
have all the lessons all the books
everything you need to complete to
finish the grade but who's educating you
you know I'm kind of educating myself
the program is educating do you have a
teacher I have a tutor very terms you do
a week maybe 10 is there anything you
miss from school like friends I never
liked any of my peers when I went to
school okay you didn't like them at all
no I what did you hate about them I
didn't connect to them I've never
connected with people my age I've never
felt like they really understood me I've
never formed close relationships with
anyone really my age all my close
friends are a good two or three years
older than me do you feel like that's
because you've traveled so much with
your dad and you've seen what he's done
and been around him enough that it kind
of makes you grow up faster you know
maybe